donc chers collègues nous accueillons à
présent monsieur Gilles séional
président de la Fédération Française de
Natation et Monsieur Laurent
tubini directeur général messieurs je
vous souhaite la bienvenue et vous
remercie de votre disponibilité pour
répondre à nos questions nous avons
entamé les travaux de cette commission
d'enquête sur l'identification des
défaillances de fonctionnement au sein
des fédérations françaises de sport du
monde sportif et des organismes de
gouvernance du monde sportif le 20
juillet dernier nos travaux portent sur
trois axes les violences physiques
sexuelles ou psychologiques dans le
sport les discriminations sexuell et
racial et les problématiques liées à la
gouvernance financière des organismes de
gouvernance du monde
sportif monsieur le Président vous avez
été élu en 2017 et réélu en 2021 vous
exercez exerciz déjà les fonctions au
sein des instances dirigeantes de la
Fédération avant votre élection puisque
vous étiez vice-président de la la
Fédération et président de la Ligue PACA
jusqu'en 2017 Monsieur le Directeur
Général vous occupez ses fonctions
depuis 2017 et présider le Cercle des
nageurs
d'entib nous avons déjà entendu le
directeur technique national de cette
fédération qui nous a décrit les actions
mises en place par votre fédération
depuis 2020 nous avons évoqué avec lui
quelques cas sur lesquels nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir je vais entamer
notre échange avec une première question
nos auditions montrent qu'il y a eu un
avant et un après 2020 la Fédération
avait fait l'objet d'un contrôle de
l'inspection générale de la Jeunesse et
des Sports en
2014 ce rapport pointait le manque
d'implication de la Fédération dans ce
domaine je le cite pas d'élu ni de
salariés référents par la commission
d'éthique pas de plan d'action national
par le Guide de
procédure pas pas d'outils de prévention
pas de programme de formation pas
d'organisation du retour de
l'information le rapport appelait la
fédération à mettre en œuvre en relation
étroite avec le ministère des Sports des
dispositifs performant d'information de
sensibilisation de prévention de
formation et d'alerte impliquant les
élus comme les cadres techniques et
concernant tant le niveau national que
le niveau territorial pouvez-vous nous
indiquer si les suites immédiates ont
été données à ce rapport le ministre des
sport a-t-il demandé à la
Fédération de de mettre en œuvre des
actions qui étaient préconisées par le
rapport de
2014 monsieur
isouini DTM en 2017 nous a indiquer que
c'est à partir de 2020 que les choses
ont été mises en place pouvez-vous nous
le confirmer
je rappelle que cette audition est
ouverte à la presse et qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale avant de vous
laisser la parole et d'entamer nos
échanges je vous rappelle que l'article
6 de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes entendues par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite donc chacun votre
tour à lever la main droite à dire je le
jure après avoir activé votre micro puis
désactivver pour laisser la parole au
suivant je le
jure je le jure je vous remercie et vous
avez la
parole merci merci madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteuse mesdames et
messieurs les députés tout d'abord je
vous remercie pour le travail que vous
effectuez sur ce sujet si complexe et si
important des violences sexuelles et de
la gouvernance des fédérations j'ai
avant d'être président de la Fédération
comme vous l'avez dit j'ai été
vice-président de cette fédération et
j'ai acquis un certain nombre de
certitude avec une volonté de tolérance
zéro et de rénovation profonde des
systèmes fédéraux c'est pourquoi après
25 ans de règne de mon prédécesseur j'ai
souhaité à la fois me porter candidat à
la Fédération pour la première fois sur
la base d'un projet et de modifier
profondément la gouvernance de notre
fédération les sujets des violences
sexuelles est venu en cours de mon
premier mandat avec toutes les crises
que nous avons traversé comme celle du
covid de l'énergie de la guerre en
Ukraine il est vrai que pour des
bénévoles engagés comme moi initialement
très orienté sur mon sport qui est au
départ la natation cette question a été
complexe à appréhender en effet notre
objet était avant tout sportif nous
souffrons donc de lacune car
originalement une fédération était
principalement chargée de l'organisation
des compétitions petit à petit notre
rôle s'est étendu il nous a été demandé
de mener diverses politiques publiques
désormais de nous engager dans le
contrôle d'honorabilité des éducateurs
de mettre en place des systèmes pour
punir les agressions sexuelles alors
même que que le système judiciaire se
voit régulièrement formuler des
reproches sur le traitement de ces
affaires je rappelle que la Fédération
Française de Natation porte cinq
disciplines olympiques la politique de
l'apprentissage de la natation et une
politique RSE très ambitieuse nous avons
porté la fédération qui était de 308000
licenciés à 402000 licenciés avec une
vraie politique de développement le
nombre de licenciés à la Fédération
étant à 54 % de femmes nous avons 60 % N
sont licenciés qui sont qui ont moins de
15 ans et dont 50 % sont des jeunes
filles je rappelle également que je
porte une volonté de parité depuis
longtemps nous sommes à une personne
prêt à la parité au CODIR nous avons
comme secrétaire général une femme et
nous avons la parité exacte dans les
vice-présidences je vais me permettre
également de décrire ce que nous avons
mis en place dans un processus global de
prévention et de lutte contre toutes les
formes d'entinte à
l'intégrité physique ou morale des
dirigeants les atteintes à l'éthique et
à la probité dans ces cinq disciplines
nous avons renforcé et structuré les
processus de lutte contre les violences
et discrimination toutes les équipe
dirigeante a choisi d'être non rémunéré
alors que c'est possible dans les
statuts de la fédération tous les achats
de la Fédération sont soumis depuis
notre élection à une procédure de marché
public nous avons créé les cercles de
compétences violence sexuelle
féminisation à en nomant des référents
madame agè Berté qui est la Directeur
Technique Nationale adjointe qui est
référence des violences sexuelles Madame
Christine marche qui est DRH à la
Fédération et qui est référente en C à
la probité vis-à-vis des salariés pour
tout problème de harcellement au travail
identification aussi dans toutes les
ligues d'un référent violence nous avons
mis en place le contrôle de
l'honorabilité des dirigeants entaînur
officiel exploitant via la plateforme
ainsi
honorabilité nous avons adopté une
charte éthique et de déontologie avec la
création d'un comité d'éthique pour en
garantir les principes un processus de
traitement des signalements qui s'est
consolidé avec le temps désormais nous
avons mis en place une cellule de
gestion des situations prioritaires
développement des formations antidopage
de violence adapté au public
développement des partenariats avec le
colosse au pied d'argile la Licra les
papillons enfin prévention des
manipulations des compétitions sportives
force de constater que malgré tout cet
arsenal mise en place nous sommes à
l'interface entre les pouvoirs publics
et les clubs d'une part et comme on
atteste la mise en place de cette
commission nous sommes perçus comme
étant maintenir un système établi ce qui
j'espère vous en conviendrait est à
l'opposé de ce que j'essaie de mener
bénévolement depuis 6 ans d'autre part
nous sommes perçus par les clubs comme
étant une institution parisienne parfois
déconnecté de la réalité des clubs ayant
toujours plus d'exigences et
d'obligations vis-à-vis des clubs il
s'agit donc aujourd'hui d'avoir un jeu
d'équilibre pour vulgariser et amener
les clubs à faire évoluer les pratiques
tout en maintenant leur volonté
d'évoluer dans un contexte de crise du
bénévola il neit aucunement les les
difficultés restent engagé à faire
évoluer chacune d'entre elles je
cisterai les nombreuses anomalies lors
du contrôle de l'honorabilité mais les
équipes restent en contact avec la
plateforme pour les remettre et les
faire remonter au niveau des
problématiques je citerai également
notre difficulté collective de
communication sur le sujet pour cela au
travers de notre nouveau site en cours
nous espérons gagner en clarté et en
lisibilité nous avons d'ailleurs pour la
première fois adresser un QR code lors
de la prise de la licence à nos 400000
licenciers je reste convainc également
que la prise de conscience de chaque
entraîneur est nécessaire pour faire
évoluer les pratiques notamment autour
du haut niveau et pour cela nous mettons
en place des formation de plus en plus
régulière avec la Direction Technique
Nationale et Monsieur Julien issoulier
son DTN le manque d'information
concernant les procédures judiciaaires
sont pour moi un vrai difficulté et
j'espère que vos conclusions permettront
de trouver un système permettant
d'éviter les pertes de suivi dans les
affaires je citerai encore la difficulté
de traiter la parole des enfants de
moins de 15 ans en matière d'agression
sexuel ou de manière très opérationnelle
la détermination du quantô de la
sanction qui n'est pas chose avisé pour
nos organes disciplinaires il me semble
qu'un accompagnement global des
fédérations sportives pourrait être une
solution afin d'harmoniser les sanctions
ou à minima de guider les organismes de
discipline voilà madame la Présidente en
conclusion de ces propos liminires je
pense que nous devons être tous très
humbles de façon à tresser ces sujets
extrêmement complexte j'estime avoir mis
en pratique mes convictions durant
l'exercice de mes fonctions bénévoles et
je reste en engagé pour faire évoluer le
système qui j'en conviens peut
évidemment encore bien s'améliorer voilà
madame la
Présidente
pardon merci merci pour ce propos
liminire et vous avez raison je pense de
rappeler
qu'effectivement cette commission
d'enquête aujourd'hui qui est mise en
place elle a pour voocation à aider en
tout cas on le souhaite les féd et le
mouvement sportif dans son ensemble à
faire en sorte que les cas qu'on a pu
constater dans le cadre de C de ces
auditions ne se reproduisent plus ou à
minima qu'on met en place les mécanismes
qui permettent de sanctionner
correctement et rapidement les auteurs
de ce de ces faits on a beaucoup entendu
caricature et cetera enfin on a entendu
beaucoup de choses sur le travail de
cette commission vous doutez bien que on
aurait peut-être préféré que ne pas
découvrir tout ce qu'on a pu ouvrir dans
le cadre de ces auditions en tout cas en
ce qui nous concerne
euh ceci étant dit peut-être moi je je
vais revenir sur peut-être une question
de madame la Présidente parce que
lorsqu'on a auditionné monsieur
issouliier donc DTN de la Fédération il
a indiqué que ce n'est qu'à partir de
2020 que les choses ont été mises en
place au niveau de de votre fédération
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous le
confirmer et puis ensuite on voudra
revenir sur une affaire précisément donc
on aura des questions là-dessus juste
avant de passer la parole à Monsieur
Laurent zubini mon directeur général
pour répondre rapidement à la présidente
effectivement vous avez notifié qu'il y
avait eu un rapport qui a été fait en
2014 ce rapport a été connu moi j'ai été
auditionné par les inspecteurs dans les
années 2016 il a sorti assez tardivement
et en fait pour tout vous dire ça a été
plutôt le départ à ma candidature parce
que j'ai eu le j'ai eu le le le temps de
it longuement avec le rapporteur et
effectivement il mettait en lumière tout
ce que moi je disais en tant que
vice-président par rapport notamment à
la gouvernance de cette fédération si
vous avez effectivement regardé cette
fédération à partir de mon élection nous
avons changé profondément la gouvernance
puisque nous avons mis le vote non plus
par des grands électeurs mais par le
vote des clubs chaque licencié pouvant
voter nous avons réduit le nombre de
mandats nous nous sommes allés sur la
parité au niveau du quorum au niveau de
la du comité directeur
puisqueaujourd'hui nous sommes à un
poste prêt déjà à la parité féminine et
nous continuons bien évidemment à à à
modifier tout ce qui peut l'être je j'ai
convient qu'il reste encore beaucoup de
choses à faire mais encore une fois
comme je l'ai dit dans les propos
liminires je pense qu'il faut il faut
savoir peser les choses ne pas brusquer
parce que nous sommes quand même face à
une crise du bénévolat aujourd'hui en
France et le sport est not ma fédération
qui représente cinq disciplines
olympiques s'appuie énormément sur le
bénévolin je tiens à rappeler que voilà
pour ce sont des exemples mais quand
vous avez un jury d'officiers sur une
compétition deation c'est plus de 35
personnes bénévoles qui donnent de leur
temps aujourd'hui on a l'obligation pour
ces bénévoles de passer je pense que
c'est bien je suis moi-même docteur en
pharmacie ils doivent passer maintenant
un brevet de secourisme mais tout ça ça
s'accumule et à un moment donné la
plupart de nos clubs sont dirigés
toujours par des bénévoles il y a encore
pas si longtemps la plupart de nos
éducateurs étaient des bénévoles il y a
eu une une évidemment une évolution par
rapport à la professionnalisation des
diplômes mais encore aujourd'hui et la
situation économique des clubs est très
bancale dans notre sport et il faut
effectivement essayer de faire en sorte
d'aller doucement mais bien sûr de
convaincre les gens par plus
d'information plus de de motivation mais
encore une fois c'est toute la
difficulté de de faire passer les
réformes mais on a su les faire passer
mais c'est un un jeu
d'équilibre peut-être juste avant avant
que vous preniez la parole peut-être une
précision donc ça j'entends sur le mode
de gouvernance sur l'élection au moment
où vous êtes élu président de la
Fédération donc le rapport vous en avez
connaissance en 2016 c'est ce que je
comprends de ce que vous nous dites et
et en fait par exemple sur le volet VSS
lutte contre les VSS qu'est-ce qui se
passe entre 2017 et 2020 qui fait que
donc monsieur isouer nous indique qu'en
fait tout est mis en place à partir de
2020 je je vais essayer de repréciser
les choses en 2014 le rapport don fait
état madame la Présidente c'est le
rapport de l'inspection général des des
sports ce ce document on en a
connaissance nous en 2017 vu que on est
on arrive en 2017 et nous reprenons un
certain nombre de préconisations dans le
plan d'action qui vient compléter le
programme de Gile saisonnial il y a un
deuxième rapport dont parle Gilles qui
est le rapport qui a été mené en 2017 il
a été interrogé en 2016 et qui lui a été
intégralement repris dans son plan
d'action entre 2014 et 2017 je n'ai
personnellement jamais retrouvé ni
contre-rendu de plan d'action de ce qui
a pu être mené entre ce rapport de
l'Inspection générale et not donc notre
arrivée en 2017 en 2017 on met en place
un certain nombre de choses notamment un
référent qui est à l'époque le
responsable juridique on met ceci en
place et on met le comité d'éthique en
place ce sont les deux deux actions on
va dire un petit peu phare de ce qui on
mis et après julienou a raison ça
commence effectivement à bouger en 2020
avec cette libéralisation de la parole
et un certain nombre d'affaires on a
traité 19 au niveau de la fédération qui
qui reviennent et qui ont qui sont
traités de bout en bout par la
Fédération juste le deuxième rapport que
vous venez d'évoquer il est de qui ce
rapport il est la Cour des comptes si je
dis pas de bêtises je l'ai sous les yeux
mais je n'ai pas le
signataire
je voilà alors du coup on va vous
demander de nous transmettre ce rapport
s'il vous plaît pour qu'on puisse en
prendre connaissance aussi puis si vous
retrouvez l'auteur c'est quand Mme
étonnant que le rapport soit pas signé
ou qu' a pas de page de
couverture j'ai une version scannée pour
pour être complètement exact et il n pas
Laage de couverture mais je vous
donnerai la version avec la page de
couverture
alors comme je vous le disais on
souhaite aussi revenir sur une affaire
qui a marqué aussi cette fédération de
de natation je pense à l'affaire Yannick
Amiel et donc dont les faits se
déroulent en 2016 et peut-être la
première question quand avez-vous
entendu parler des faits qui ont été
reprochés à Yannick annel peut-être pour
rappeler pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas cette affaire donc pour mémoire Anel
a été mis en examen en décembre 2021
pour viol sur une mineur de 13 ans fille
de Lionel orterre donc cadre d'État
ancien entraîneur notamment de Monsieur
Aniel et de de l'ancienne ministre des
Sports madame Roxana Marie signanou et
DTN de la Fédération avec qui il a
reconnu avoir entretenu une relation ce
qui est interdit par la loi et placé
sous le statut de témoin assisté pour
une autre affaire d'agression sexuelle
donc peut-être première question à quel
moment vous avez connaissance des faits
qui lui sont
reprochés alors c'est relativement
on va
dire malheureusement inscrit c'était on
était au championnat de France à
Montpellier quand le c'est l'affaire a
été dans la presse et c'est uniquement à
ce moment-là que nous avons eu
connaissance effectivement de cette
affaire avant il n a jamais eu en ce qui
nous concerne de remonter à la
Fédération si vous pouvez nous préciser
la date et le mois en tout cas puisque
vous nous parlez de de date de
championnat
on va vous le retrouver parce que c'est
très facile on é en voiture et c'est le
jour où l'affaire éclate dans les médias
c'est ce
jour-làamp de France National ok est-ce
que c'est en décembre
ok monsieur issouliier le DTN indiqué à
la commission d'enquête avoir été
prévenu par le père de la victime donc
monsieur Horter au moment où les faits
sortent dans la presse on était tous
surpris a-t-il affirmé devant nous c'est
vraiment arrivé sans signau avantcoureur
est-ce que c'est la même Mme chose pour
vous totalement ça a été un électrochoc
hein dans la piscine parce que encore
une fois ce sont des des choses qui vous
tombent dessus on pouvait pas imaginer
en en ayant
effectivement il faut préciser qu'à
cette époque là Aniel n'était plus à la
fédération ne nageait plus il n'était
plus l'essentiel à la Fédération hein
puisque les années avaient un petit peu
passé nous je veux dire évidemment on a
côtoyé ce nageur on a côtoyé aussi euh
Lionel Orter qui était le DTN comme vous
l'avez précisé de la fédération à aucun
moment lonel nous a évoqué
ce aucun aucun aucun à aucun moment quoi
je veux dire il y a pas eu desformation
pouvant nous laisser supposer après les
gens évidemment quand on vous dit c'est
pas possible c'est pas bah si parce que
il y a jamais eu rien qui a filtré de de
cette
histoire pourtant la la cellule
d'investigation de radio France estime
que plusieurs membres de l'entourage
étaient au courant et que la relation
qui existait entre donc l'ancien
champion olympique et la fille de
lionelterre était connu par des nageurs
et nageuses de l'ép de l'époque qu'en
pensez-vous nous l'avons entendu
également mais je peux vous affirmer
nous étions ensemble quand nous l'avons
appris que cette affaire a été portée à
notre connaissance en décembre 21
effectivement vous avez la bonne date et
et ce que je voulais vous dire c'est que
l'affaire est en cours et que nous
sommes partie civil notre partie civile
a été accepté après premier rejet et que
donc on attend aussi nous aussi le
jugement pour pouvoir discuter aussi de
cette affaire un peu plus
profondément alors pareil donc au moment
de son audition monsieur issouier nous a
indiquer avoir été informé par Monsieur
Horter au moment où l'affaire sort dans
la presse donc décembre 2021 qui lui
aurait dit savoir depuis quelques
semaines ou quelques mois et il a
prévenu que l'affaire allait sortir dans
la presse et que ça allait secouer
est-ce que il s'agit de plusieurs
semaines ou de plusieurs mois c'est pas
clair alors ce sont des propos qui
engagent monsieur isoui monsieur isoui
quand il a eu connaissance de cette
information mais elle est le même jour
que le le jour où ça sort dans la presse
il il en fait état au président voilà
après ce qu' se sont dit avec Monsieur
Horter on nétait pas là mais
effectivement Julien isoui nous a
confirmé et qu'il avait une conversation
avec Monsieur hter qui lui avait bien
dit qu'il l'avait appris il y a quelques
moi et on peut lire dans la presse que
la fille de Monsieur Orter a déposé
plainte en juillet 2021 et comment la
Fédération peut nêre être informée qu'en
décembre j'ai envie de vous dire comme
d'habitude madame la Présidente ce qui
est triste c'est qu'il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de communication fluide
entre la justice et les fédérations il y
en a aucune les signalements qu'on a pu
faire sur ce cas ou sur d'autres on n
pas de
suivi
oui ça on entend parfaitement cette
difficulté de relation mais ce qui nous
ce qui nous interroge c'est que orterre
était DTN de la Fédération donc voilà
c'est dire qu'il a même pas eu en
interne de la Fédération pas
d'information à cette épo là il est plus
DTN depuis longtemps déjà il faut
rappeler que bah d'abord les liens qu'il
avait avec l'ancien président et lonel
Orter qui qui avait été choisi par
Francis Suisse président de la
Fédération puisque nous avons eu à
l'époque Christian donzier qui est
décédé qui était le directeur t national
et donc lonel Orter a été choisi par le
président de la fédération pour être DTN
ensuite suite à une action de ministère
lonel ofter n'a pas pu poursuivre sa sa
mission puisqu'il avait à l'époque aussi
on va
dire un emploi dans son club et donc le
ministère a fait en sorte effectivement
de dire que ce n'était pas possible de
continuer les deux missions donc pour en
revenir à ce que vous dites madame la
rapporteuse il n'était plus du tout DTN
il était juste l'entraîneur du club de
Milous depuis quelques années
donc
pardon juste j'ai retrouvé dans mes
notes on a appris l'information le 9
décembre 2021
oui j'entends qu'il était peut-être plus
d't mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il
était un corp euh cadre dans au au seinf
en tout cas il était entraîneur au au
niveau de la
Fédération il était plus euh il était
plus DTN il avait plus de mission au
niveau de la Fédération hein il son son
son rôle a été voilà du jour qu'il a été
entre guillemets mis dans l'obligation
de quitter ses fonctions par le
ministère il était plus euh plus du tout
en mission pour la
fédération en en tout état de cause pour
être extrêmement précis il même s'il
était agent d'État il était sous la
responsabilité du Julen isouliier et
Julien isoulier a été informé au même
moment que nous des fait c'estàdire que
même si lui l'a su plusutôt il ne l'a
pas remonté à sa hiérarchie
ok donc vous nous vous pouvez nous
confirmer que la Fédération n'a jamais
entendu parler des relations entre la
fille de Monsieur Orter et de Yannick
Aniel avant que l'affaire ne sorte dans
la
presse moi je peux vous le confirm bien
sûr
ok la commission d'enquête a demandé à
Monsieur isoulier de confirmer que le
club était donc informé donc plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois euh monsieur
isoulier nous a indiqué que le club
n'était pas informé seulement la famille
pouvez-vous nous dire qui était le
président du
club je vais le vérifier mais ça doit
être franc Orter le frère de lelor à ce
moment-là je vais quand même le vérifier
si vous me permettez non non c'était
confiance c'était monur monsieur Orter
qui était toujours le président du club
c'est à son décès qu'ensuite son fils a
pris Franck Orter a pris la la
présidence du
club en fait je vous pose la question
parce que c'était effectivement le frère
donc quand on dit que la famille était
bien informé c'estàd que le président du
club éta
informé difficile de répondre encore une
fois moi je suis pas un intime de la
famille hterre donc à un moment donné
nous on a découvert comme comme Julien
lissoulier l'a dit on l'a appris on
était en voiture ensemble pour aller à
Montpellier avec mon directeur voilà
après ce qui les
échanges je je me souviens très bien
avoir été interviewé par les radios et
les médias et c'est vrai que j'avais dit
que c'était voilà on découvre une
situation et que je crois que j'ai dit à
l'époque que c'était quelque chose qui
était de mon point de vue tout à fait à
éviter de toutes les façons dans
l'avenir par rapport au fait que on
puisse accueillir que ça soit une jeune
fille dans une famille ou l'inverse je
veux dire ça pose des problèmes des
problématique en tant que cadre d'État
et père de la victime monsieur Orter
naurait-il pas dû faire un signalement
dès qu'il a eu la connaissance des
faits selon les procédures actuelles
oui
en fait peut-être on va vous demander de
préciser parce que l'article 40 date
c'est pas une procédure d'aujourd'hui ça
existe je pense depuis
longtemps 40 effectivement existe depuis
longtemps mais le fait de dire que un
cas d'état doit faire dans ce cas là un
article 40 c'est quand même quelque
chose qui a été mis en place plus
récemment et plus systématisé avant
évidemment l'article 40 existit et
évidemment il aurait pu le faire avant
mais au regard des procédures actuelles
c'est vrai que c'est systématisé ce que
ce n'était pas le cas
avant aujourd'hui dans dans la procédure
actuelle de la Fédération avec la
cellule qu'on a mis pour traiter les les
dossiers prioritaires effectivement
autour de moi-même avec les directeur
technique national directeur général
avec le le responsable du du juridique
et effectivement euh on traite les
affaires très rapidement et s'il a lieu
on dépose un article 40
immédiatement
la cellule d'investigation de Radio
France indique notamment d'autres
nageurs de l'époque se demande comment
les parents de la victime Lionel et
Margerie hard omniprésent dans la vie du
club en particulier lors des stage à
l'étranger on pu ne rien voir lors de
leur audition par les enquêteurs le 15
juillet 2021 ces derniers ont indiqué
avoir eu connaissance des faits de
semaines seulement avant que leur fill
ne porte plainte soit en début des
vacances d'été 2021 visiblement en
souffrance leur aurait-on raconté ce qui
s'était passé avec Yannick
Aniel mais de nombreuses personnes
proches du mon c'est le nom du club
j'imagine s'interroge sur cette version
c'est le cas d'un ancien d'un ancien
cadre du club qui nous raconte cet
épisode remontant à fin mars début 2000
début avril 2021 pardon 2019 le mon est
alors en conflit avec Yannick Aniel qui
le réclame 60000 € pour sa dernière
année de contrat au club celui-ci ne lui
aurait pas été payé celle-ci pardon le
club envoie alors une lettre de
conciliation franc corter président du
mon et frère de Lionel
ne me dit que nous dit que que Yannick
serait alors serait sage pardon
d'accepter
cette conciliation car ils ont un
dossier sur lui et sa niè raconte cet
ancien cadre que saviez-vous vous pour
votre
part absolument rien on l'a découvert
avec l'investigation de de Radio France
et on a appris aussi que des nageurs
aurait été au courant mais jamais ça
n'est remonté à la fédération en tout
cas nous n'avons aucun écrit de cette
époque- là à la
Fédération après on peut rajouter que
effectivement ce qu'on ce qu'on savait
c'était qu'il y avait un un un différent
d'ordre financier entre le club et
Yannie ganiel ça c'est évident après de
là à dire que il y aurait eu entre
guillemets une un essai d'arrangement
entre la famille hterre et Yannick par
rapport à ça nous on n jamais eu aucune
information là-dessus hein encore une
fois c'est c'est ça paraît
voilà et et et peut-être pour compléter
effectivement le différent qui a eu lieu
sur les 62000 € de mémoire il a été
réglé il a été et de ce que j'en sais le
club a payé et à honorer cette dette
auprès de Yanni
Aniel mais alors justement vous n'étiez
pas informé au moment peut-être des
discussions en tout cas vous n'avez pas
eu connaissance de ce que rapporte cet
ancien cadre sur cette affaire sur cette
tentative de conciliation mais à la
suite des révéliations puisque vous
dites que vous avez appris ça au moment
des révélations de de Radio France
est-ce que la Fédération a ouvert une
enquête une à chercher à en savoir plus
justement sur cette tentative de de
conciliation alors alors non parce qu'à
l'époque c'était pour nous une
problématique privée entre le club et
l'athlète et c'était déjà devant les
tribunaux donc je vois pas trop sur
cette affaire comment nous aurions pu
intervenir mais peut-être que je vous
vous voyez quelque chose que je ne vois
pas en fait au moment où vous découvrez
cette affaire euh donc vous êtes informé
par voie de presse de cette affaire et
ensuite il y a Radio France qui donne
plusieurs éléments en tout cas plusieurs
éléments nouveaux dont vous n'avez dont
vous n'aviez pas connaissance donc
notamment le fait que il y a eu une
tentative de conciliation selon cet
ancien cadre nous pareil que vous on
reprend les éléments qui ont été donnés
à la presse mais aussi sur le fait que
plusieurs personnes étaient informées
visiblement de cette relation et donc ma
question c'est bien sûr c'est vous
n'avez pas ouvert de d'enquête sur cette
relation de Concil enfin cette tentative
de conciliation entre le club et la tête
mais est-ce que vous avez tenté de
savoir qui savait puisque plusieurs
personnes semblaient être informé de
cette relation est-ce que de ce point de
vue-là vous avez cherché à comprendre
peut-être est-ce qu'il y avait des
adultes d'autres personnes qui étaient
au courant de cette relation et qui
n'ont pas fait remonter
l'information parant du principe que le
Père nous disait ne pas être au courant
c'est que ça nous semblait extrêmement
complexe après procédure en engagé par
le procureur donc nous on s'est porté
parti civile pour avoir accès au dossier
avoir les informations et en tirer par
la suite les conséquences parce qu'il y
aura peut-être suite au procès des
conséquences à en tirer mais c'est
difficile de venir faire une enquête sur
une enquête de justice en tout cas alors
je parle pas de faire une enquête en
même temps que l'enquête de justice mais
à partir du moment où Radio France
révèle que visiblement des nageurs des
nageuses qui sont licenciés chez vous
étaient informé de cela est-ce que vous
n'avez pas vous cherché à comprendre
justement qui savait euh à ce moment-là
et de faire remonter justement tout ces
informations non on l'a pas fait mais on
trouvait ça pas légitime forcément de le
faire mais là encore on est dans
un une besoin de progression mais c'est
vrai que nous on n pas pensé que c'était
utile de le
faire après après je pense aussi que et
sans vouloir remettre en cause ce qu'a
dit Radio France mais entre ce qui a été
dit à ce
moment sur les uns et les autres c'est
quand même très difficile de faire la
part des choses d'un côté vous avez les
parents qui sont quand même les premiers
concernés on peut quand même
légitimement je je suis un parents un
grand-père enfin je sais pas moment
donné ça ça me paraît tellement énorme
que j'ai du mal à à à rentrer dans ce
schéma de de ce qui a été dit après que
que les d'autres nageurs a été au
courant mais dans ce cas-là ils ont
jamais rien fait remonter non plus alors
peut-être qu'effectivement là on peut
dire que nous on n pas bon ement mais
aussi pourquoi la parole ne remonte pas
si si tant de gens savaient enfin ça
paraît et et vous avez dit madame la
Présidente effectivement ils étaient
présents au stage ils étaient présents
comment se fait-il que enfin je vois
bien nous on appel ça notre jargon les
Arab au bord du bassin mais comment se
fait-il que ça soit jamais remonté quoi
c'est après d'un côté vous avez des
parents qui avaient l'air plus
qu'effondré c'est difficile de d'être
jugé parti après je je c'est pas pour se
dédoiner mais encore une fois yanniiken
n'était plus licencié je dire c'est
difficile de rentrer dans une affaire ou
même quand on a voulu se porter partie
civile on nous a on nous a rebouté la
première fois
quoi alors peut-être pour préciser un
peu les choses il s'agit pas ici de
savoir
euh enfin vous avez dit on n pas bien
fait enfin c'est vraiment c'est pas le
sujet nous ce qu'on essaie de déterminer
c'est peut-être les processus et comment
ils sont mis en place et peut-être
comment aussi faire en sorte qu'il y ait
des process qui soi voilà
institutionnalisé pour justement ce type
d'affaire particulièrement parce que
vous voyez vous nous dites oui comment
ça se fait que il y avait plein de
personnes qui étaient informées que
l'information soit par remontée c'est ce
qu'on retrouve quasiment partout
c'est-à-dire que dans plusieurs
fédérations qu'on a pu entendre ici par
des victimes ou d'ailleurs même par des
présidents de fédération on nous parle
de bruit de bruit persistant sur
certaines affaires et c'est vrai que
l'automatisme ce qu'on a pu constater
n'est pas d'ouvrir une enquête en tout
cas de chercher à comprendre ce qui se
dit et c'est là où peut-être nous on se
dit qu'il y a un enjeu
euh au bout d'un moment quand les bruits
deviennent persistants qu'il y a
plusieurs personnes qui sont informées
comment on fait déjà pour que ça suive
une voi euh spécifique pour faire
remonter l'information au niveau de la
fédération ou d'ailleurs auprès d'autres
dispositifs tels que signal sport ou
alors comment est-ce que la Fédération
elle-même peut ouvrir euh des moyens de
d'enquêter euh par des procédures
disciplinaires ou d'autres hein il y a
des dispositifs qui existent pour
justement chercher à comprendre et à
savoir qui se passe et si vous voulez
c'est là en fait on a des interrogations
parce que ce que vous nous dites là en
fait plus plusieurs autres nous l'ont
dit aussi c'est pas spécifique à votre
fédération après pour être plus précis
je pense que si nous avions eu ces
bruits sur une affaire qui n'était pas
traitée par la justice nous aurions avec
l'organisme de discipline puu qu'on a
des instructeur on a renforcé le service
juridique nous avons maintenant trois
personnes qui gèent au service juridique
ces enquêtes nous aurions déclenché
quelque chose mais c'est vrai que comme
du coup on a été saisi après du coup
c'était plus difficile d'aller chercher
un petit peu on aurait pu faire de du
bruit sur la ligne de la justice c'est
ça qu'on voulait pas non plus c'est pour
ça qu'on l'a pas fait à ce moment-là sur
cette affaire
là alors qui a fait le signalement dans
cette affaire et à quel
moment dans cette affaire il y a pas
d'article 40 il y a pas de signal sport
puisque la sais c'est la justice qui est
saisie d'abord
ok parce
que monsieur issouier nous a indiqué que
c'est signal sport qui fait le
signalement et donc ma question c'était
qui après venu signal sport en tout cas
c'est pas nous s'il y a eu un signal
sport c'est pas nous c'est la c'est à
mon sens la famille mais je je peux le
chercher je peux vous retrouver les les
éléments et à quel moment le ministère
des Sports est-il informé et pr et que
préconise-t-il je pense que le le le le
ministère des Sports il s'est retrouvé
dans la même situation que nous c'est
qu'il a appris l'affaire par les médias
et à cette moment-là je pense qu'on n
pas eu d'échange avec la ministre de
l'époque alors Monsieur monsieur isouier
nous a indiqué que les capacités de
réaction de la Fédération étaient
réduite car monsieur annel n'était plus
licencié de la fédération à ce moment-là
donc à partir de quel moment il n'a plus
étéc à votre dans votre
fédération laissez-moi juste un instant
comme ça je vous donne la date
exacte 2016 madame la
rapporteur depuis le 15 septembre 2016
il n'est plus lessentié à la Fédération
et avez avez-vous connaissance d'autres
relations entre des entraînurs
enentation et des nageurs ou nageuses
mineurs et la question qui suit c'est de
combien de cas de violence VSS avez-vous
eu connaissance ces dernières années
alors nous avons traité en tout 19 àire
7 en 2020 2 en 2021 4 en 2022 6 en
2023 toutes non pas donner des suites
les mêmes suites he nous avons eu un cas
pour violence sexuelle pure un cas pour
maltraitance bisutage 1ès atteintes à
l'intégrité physique et moral de
harcèlement physique et moral et 17 faut
contre l'honneur et la bienséance c'est
une infraction un peu générique dans
lequel on met l'ensemble des des
infractions il y a eu des suspensions on
a tout un recueil qui a été donné sur
les suites qu'on donné sur chacun des
cas
donc j'imagine que vous avez la
traçabilité des entraîneurs mis en
cause nous avons bien évidemment la
transçabilité puisque il y a la
possibilité de suspendre la licence pour
plus ou moins long terme et nous avons
un fichers centralisés avec des
identifiants uniques par licencier et
donc si vous êtes entre guillemets
suspendu de licence vous ne pouvez plus
avoir une une licence à la
Fédération à la
Fédération c'est important de le dire
parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
fichier centralisé sur l'ensemble donc
ça veut dire que il y a un risque je
suis entraîneur à natation je vais à la
nage avec
palme voilà et C adolescents ont porté
plainte contre leur entraîneur de
natation en Goulem pouvez-vous nous dire
comment cette affaire a été traitée par
la
FFN
alorsmi
ou
angoulem vous avez le nom de du cas ou
pas du
tout c'est dans la presse tout
simplement en date du 26 avril 2022
je alors là je excusez-moi madame la
Présidente mais je connais pas ce cas
donc je vais le regarder plus en détail
je vous fournirai les éléments il est
noté 5 adolescentes ont porté plainte
contre leur entraîneur de natation
angoulem elle dénonce du harcèlement et
des agressions sexueles selon les
informations révélées par la Charente
Libre placé en garde à vue le 26 avril
l'homme de 23 ans de 33 ans pardon est
ressorti libre de son
audition
je regarde et je vous donne les éléments
je ne connais pas le cas tout de suite
là alors si vous alors sur les
différents cas que vous avez pu nous
transmettre les 19 affaires ça veut dire
que celle-ci n'en fait pas
partie ça c'est sûr sauf si je l'ai mal
classé mais mais
je pour vous assurer que c'est pas dans
mes
19 ça c'est certain sauf si c'est pas la
bonne ville ou pas le bon club que je
l'ai sous le nom de club mais je
vais oui du coup on se questionne parce
que c'est un peu étonnant qu'une affaire
soit dans la presse que il y a une
personne qui a été mise en visiblement
en garde à vue et qu'il soit
ressorti cinq adolescentes et que vous
vous n'ayez pas eu l'information ça veut
dire que c'est par remonté jusqu'à vous
en fait moi j'ai les les statistiques
par nom de d'entraîneur donc si vous
avez le nom non je peux vous le dire
tout de suite si on peut pas le citer je
le cite pas mais mais
je j'en ai un qui est dans le même
département qui pourrait être cette
personne-là et si c'est bien cette
personnlà à laquelle je pense il y a eu
18 modes suspension euh et entraîur de
l'ANC laissez-moi chercher un peu plus
ANC est en Goulem natation
charante
angoulem bon je ferai des recherche
parce que ça il faut que je vérifie
parce que des fois quand on dit
entraînur datation c'est peut-être ça
peut être de la nage avec
c'est bien le cas ok donc on me confirme
que c'est le cas
euh donc
effectivement l'entraîneur en question
il aurait adopté un comportement
intrusif il fait bien partie des 19 il a
eu 18 mois de suspension dont 12 avec
surc donc excusez-moi c'est moi qui
n'avait pas fait le lien avec le le
club et donc il est suspendu ça date de
il a été suspendu alors ça date de 2022
ça date de
2022 donc a priori devrait plus être
suspendu et vous savez où
où travaille cet
entraîneur alors où il
travaille déjà son nom mais je n'ai pas
son prénom donc ça va être difficile de
retrouver tout de suite mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'est plus
licencié à confirmer et je vous le
confirmerai par écrit mais a priori il
n'est plus
licencié ok donc
euh donc il a été suspendu vous savez
pas s'il est licencié ou pas mais du
coup c'est pareil que pour les autres
c'estàd s'il change et qu'il va
ailleurs comment ça se passe ensuite
pour le
suivience si si l'organisme de
discipline est suspendu 18 mois au bout
de 18 mois il peut
retravailler donc du coup il peut
reprendre une licence là-dessus voilà il
peut retravailler même à la Fédération
de
natation
alors Monsieur bah Yannick Anel je
retourne un tout petit peu en arrière a
été hébergé au domicile même de Lionnel
h terre où certains faits se sont
produits il l'aurait installé chez lui
pour superviser au plus près sa
préparation et son hygiène de vie dans
la perspective des Jeux olympiques de
Rio la Fédération savait-elle et
acceptait-elle qu'un entraîneur héberge
un athlète chez lui pour superviser sa
préparation ben je pense que oui de
toute façon c'était on prenait la l'
année que c'était c'était avant les Jeux
de Rio donc c'était en
2015-26 euh faudrait poser la question à
mon prédécesseur mais je pense
qu'effectivement encore une fois c'est
on retombe toujours dans ce qui serait
dans un monde parfait moi je suis le
premier à dire qu'il faut éviter tout ça
aujourd'hui euh je peux vous citer des
cas je dirai pas les noms ou c'est des
parents qui nous quand j viensouliier le
leur essay de leur faire comprendre que
c'est pas bien d'aller mettre leur
filles chez un entraîneur et ou un
garçon hein prenons soyons
et dans ce cas-là les parents disent ben
si vous m'embembêtez pour pas dire un
gros mot on va le faire émanciper comme
ça vous aurez rien à dire quoi alors que
c'est un enfant mineur après c'est toute
la difficulté aussi he d'arriver à faire
comprendre les choses parce que c'est
mon point de vue et je suis attaché à ça
mais mais c'est vrai que c'est des fois
compliqué très compliqué on pourrait
citer des grands exemples par le passé
ça s'est bien passé il y a pas eu de
problème mais des jeunes filles ou des
jeunes garçons qui vont chez
l'entraîneur et dans d'autres sports je
lis aussi les journaux il y a eu
beaucoup de de problématiques du
effectivement à ce genre de comportement
des fois ça se passe mal ou ça peut bien
se passer mais c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faudrait totalement
éviter de mon point de vue alors vous
avez dit essayer de faire comprendre et
que c'est compliqué donc ça veut dire
que à l'heure actuelle vous avez un cor
des nageurs ou des nageuses qui sont
hébergés chez leur
entraîneur je je pense qu'il en moins en
moins nous c'est une préconisation que
l'on donne c'est un travail qu'on a on a
parlé avec Julien isoulier donc on veut
mettre pour les structures du plan de
performance fédérale on veut mettre ça
comme une obligation mais c'est
effectivement un changement de culture
aujourd'hui il existe encore des gens
hébergés chez le entraîneur ça existe il
faut que ça disparaisse mais c'est c'est
un long chemin parce qu'économiquement
on on reste dans la natation qui est un
sport basé sur le bénévolat et qui peut
être extrêmement complexe financièrement
pour les familles de trouver une
structure d'accueil aujourd'hui dans nos
structures du PPF on demande à ce qu'il
y ait des internats qu'il ait des CREPS
en support de manière à
sécuriser tout le dispositif à des coûts
relatifs si demain on dit à tout le
monde c'est terminé je pense qu'on va
avoir un trou dans la raquette
générationnelle donc aujourd'hui si on
comprend bien il peut arriver que qu'un
majeur dorme dans la même chambre qu'un
mineur dans ce type de
contexte la même chambre non et
particulièrement en AB après on n'est
pas derrière tout le monde mais non
c'est c'est c'est ça peut être un
accueil effectivement chez une personne
mais c'est pas c'est pas du tout la même
chambre partager alors peut-être juste
pour préciser monsieur isoulier nous a
nous a évoqué enfin il nous a parlé des
clubs qui partent en championnat qui
optent pour de l'airbnb par exemple donc
la question c'est plutôt sur ce type là
c'estàdire qu'and on Airbnb est-ce que
il arrive que vous ayez des mineurs qui
dorment dans la même chambre qu' adulte
qu'un entraîneur ou autre parce que ils
font le choix d'un herbn dit
justement moi je connais pas ce cas
honnêtement C longtemps longtemps dans
les dans les stages dans les que ça soit
dans la ligue ça soit voilà de façon que
ça soit la Fédération et bien évidemment
chaque nageur ou nageuse est dans sa
chambre ou en tout cas partage la
chambre peut-être avec un collègue ou
une collègue mais de toutes les façons
il est hors de question vis-à-vis de la
Fédération queil puisse y avoir ce genre
de comportement et de toute façon je
peux vous assurer que tout est fait pour
réserver les chambres sont séparés et on
essaye effectivement à chaque fois
d'avoir des
accompagnatrices féminines pour
s'occuper des jeunes filles avec des
accompagnateurs masculins où la
difficulté peut se poser c'est ce que je
vous disais dans les propos liminires
c'est que vous pouvez très bien avoir un
club qui va dans un championnat pas
forcément championnat d'élite mais un
championnat interrégional ou une et
effectivement pour des pour des
réductions de coût va essayer de mettre
plusieurs nageurs ensemble dans la même
chambre moi à ma connaissance non ils
dorment pas c'est ça c'est hors de
question en tout cas c'est la
préconisation qu'on va faire qu'on fait
déjà depuis longtemps que ça soit dans
les ligues dans lespartement ou
effectivement la
Fédération il faut voilà oui quand vous
parlez de préconisation et monsieur
isoui nous a évoqué des recommandations
il disait on recommande de prendre de
chambres est-ce que ce sont est-ce que
c'est des préconisation recommandation
écrite et clair c'està dire adressé
clairement ou est-ce que ce sont des
recommandations à l'oral au moment des
déplacements qui sont faits aux
personnes et aux clubs qui se déplacent
alors quand c'est des des
des quand c'est des déplacements
fédéraux c'est la règle elle est je sais
pas si elle est écrite mais en tout cas
il n'y a pas ce type de comportement ou
de là-dessus ça c'est
certain ce qu'on vous a proposé comme
évolution c'est dans le projet de
performance fédérale de l'inscrire comme
une comme un prérequis donc ça va
devenir une règle donc ça c'est notre
objectif après aujourd'hui comme l'a dit
Gill on a 1300 clubs 1300 clubs on peut
pas savoir tout ce qui se passe dans les
1300 clubs et on ne peut pas non plus on
ne dirige pas non plus des 1300 clubs on
peut faire aussi des préconisations mais
je pense que suite à tout ce qu'on est
en train de se dire nous allons l'écrire
formellement je pense que vous auriez
raison de l'écrire
formellement
peut-être des questions concernant le
contrat de
délégation avez-vous rempli et transmis
le tableau envoyé par la Direction des
Sports sur le bilan du contrat de
délégation et est-ce que vous avez
rencontré Madame Bourdet pour faire un
point sur l'application de ce contrat
nous avons rempli donc c'est notre
directrice nationale adjointe AG qui l'a
rempli et qui nous l'a soumis et le
rendez-vous avec Madame Bourdet est
prévu de mémoire le
euh début décembre ou non pardon le la
semaine prochaine 29
[Musique]
novembre novembre novembre
excusez-moi 29 décembre c'est un peu ser
dur à à
10h et eu nous sommes extrêmement
surpris parce que par la lecture de
votre contrat de délégation dans le
volet lutte contre les violences il se
contente de décrire ce que vous avez
déjà fait on peut lire que la FFF a
nommé un référent VSS laffff a entamé un
dialogue avec les associations sur le
contrôle de
l'honorabilité la FNN est parvenue à
contrôler plus des tro/4 des licenciés
soumis au contrôle une page lutte contre
les maltraitances a été créée sur le
site dont on a pu relevé qu'elle ne
renvoie pas vers signal sport la FNN a
mis en place une procédure dédiée de
traitement et de
signalement j'ai pas j'ai pas compris ce
qui vous choquer
excusez-moi il faut voilà peut-être pour
préciser sur ce contrat vous avez listé
ce que vous avez déjà réalisé euh donc
quels sont vos objectifs en matière de
lutte contre les VSS de dispositifs que
vous souhaitez mettre en place peut-être
si vous avez la page de lutte contre les
maltraitances peut-être que l'un des
objectifs serait de renvoyer sur signal
sport je sais pas voilà moi je je vais
pas le rédiger pour vous et vos
engagement pour voilà quels sont vos
engagement alors comme Gill vous l'a dit
en introduction sur l'aspect signalement
bien sûr qu'on va renvoyer sur signal
sport et bien sûr qu'on va avoir un
onglet sur notre site Web qui renverra
au bon endroit comme vous vous l'a dit
Julien on est en pleine rénovation de
notre site Web et il sort la semaine
prochaine donc l'objectif c'est que
c'est que tout ceci so soit parfaitement
parfaitement fait nous nous notre
objectif c'est que que l'ensemble enfin
g l'a dit sa volonté c'est tolérance
zéro donc c'est ce qu'on essaie
d'appliquer chaque jour dans tous les
dossiers avec toutes les difficultés que
ça peut
engendrer alors je vais revenir
peut-être vraiment sur sport parce que
au moment où on a auditionné monsieur
isouier il a reconnu justement que la
Fédération n'encourageait pas les
licenciés à se tourner vers signal sport
et privilégier les circuits de
signalement interne à la Fédération
d'ailleurs je on vous l'a dit le votre
page lutte contre les maltraitances ne
renvoie pas aujourd'hui sur signal sport
et par qui a été confirmé cette page qui
ne renvoie pas vers signal sport est-ce
qu'il y a un un endroit un moment où
vous avez décidé finalement de ne pas
renvoyer sur la cellule signal sport il
y a un choix qui a été fait de garder en
interne les
signalements alors ce qui ce qui a été
créé c'est un cercle de compéten qui est
dédié à la au suivi de la de des
violences sexuel donc c'est lui qui est
compétent et qui détermine les
procédures en lien avec le comité de
donontologie donc les procédures qui ont
été créées elles sont soumises au comité
d'étiquets d'ontologie qui a validé
cette procédure si
[Musique]
euh il y avait la volonté euh de de de
donner tous les canaux possible c'estàd
que nous avons fait quatre partenariats
le colossopé d'argile les papillons la
Licra et j'en oubliant là tout de suite
mais on a fait quatre partenariats avec
des associations spécialisées pour
mailler parce que notre difficulté c'est
que nos licenciés sont extrêmement
jeunes ils ont à 60 % moins de 15 ans
donc la volonté c'est d'arriver à
trouver un moyen pour arriver à les
faire parler donc en fait les
associations spécialisées nous
semblaient bien meilleur que nous
pouvions l'être et et voilà et donc le
le signal sport du coup il est pris par
l'association en deuxè rideau voilà
c'est pour ça qu'on a maillé cette chose
là de cette manière là mais encore une
fois dans le nouveau site il y a bien le
lien aussi vers signal sport
voilà est-ce que c'était aussi une
demande de la Direction des Sports de
que vous puissiez renvoyer sur signal
sport est-ce qu'on vous a fait une
remarque là-dessus ou pas du tout ça a
jamais été abordé alors auprès nous non
mais je pense qu'auprès de la direction
tech naationale ça a été abordé vu que
comme je vous le dis la transmission à
Signal sport elle elle va
devenir automatique et elle est déjà
faite si stématiquement par les équipes
de la DTN par notre référente violence
sexuelle annès Berté
oui oui ce qu'on se disait c'est que que
vous vous renvoyez à Signal sport c'est
important mais en fait la cellule a été
aussi mise en place pour permettre aux
victimes de pouvoir s'exprimer en dehors
de leur fédération et de leur et de leur
club justement pour éviter le fait que
parfois on ait le sentiment que
l'affaire soit pas traitée à la à la à à
la juste mesure donc je pense que c'est
voilà et d'ailleurs on a beaucoup
beaucoup entendu parler de cette cellule
signal sport dans cette commission
d'enquête sur le fait qu'elle manquait
de visibilité et de compréhension pour
les victimes et pour le grand public
donc je pense que pour le coup le fait
de clarifier et d'indiquer les
différentes procédures qui peuvent
exister pour une victime permet de
faciliter aussi la libération de la
parole quand une victime a le choix de
pouvoir saisir n'importe quelle instance
quand elle le
souhaite justement sur la la procédure
décrite sur votre site indique pour des
raisons de confidentialité de la
procédure afin de protéger les personnes
en cause dans l'attente du déclenchement
des mesures qui s'impose la divulgation
d'information à des médias ne saurait se
faire sans l'accord du référent lutte
contre les violences de la FFN est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer peut-être
ce
passage je je le comprends mais est-ce
que je peux vous l'expliquer là tout de
suite
non d'ailleurs c'est c'est sur la fiche
vous l'avez lu parce qu'en fait on a une
fiche de trois pages qui est accessible
et et vous avez lu ça où parce que du
coup je je trouve
pas vous me redites d'autre passag s'il
vous
plaît excusez-moi hein on
recherche pardon sinon je peux pas
reprendre la parole on va vous on va
vous le retrouver vous voulez que je
vous le relise le passage alors pour des
raisons de confidentialité de la
procédure afin de protéger les personnes
en cause dans l'attente du déclenchement
des mesures qui s'imposent la
divulgation d'informations à des médias
ne saurait se faire sans l'accord du
référent lutte contre les
violences de la
Fédération alors je vous confirme que
c'est sur le site il y a sur un onglet
faire cesser la violence sexuelle
présumée
donc voilà il y a écrit dès qu'un
dirigeant prend connaissance de tel fait
il doit prendre les décisions
nécessaires pour assurer la sécurité de
la victime présumé notamment en écartant
l'auteur présumé via une mesure
conservatoire et ensuite le paragraphe
que je vous ai lu
ok mais vous enfin vous trouvez malsin
le fait de de de demander enfin de ce
que je comprends mais j'ai peut-être mal
j'ai pas sous les yeux justeexliquer ce
que vous voulez dire par je je je ne
l'ai pas écrit je je ne vais pas je ne
vais pas l'interpréter je le comprends
comme protéger les différents
intervenants en traitant d'abord cette
ce cas avant de d'en en parler à la
presse voilà c'est tout ce que je
comprends mais encore une fois je ne
l'ai pas écrit et ça me semble logique
vu comme
ça et d'ailleurs votre site renvoie vers
le comité éthique et sport mais ce
comité a été dissou en avril 2022 ça
fait partie des modifications
effectivement nous n'avons plus de
partenariat avec le comité éthique et
sport depuis cette dissolution un petit
peu avant même puisqu'il y avait
effectivement certain nombre de
problèmes avec ce comité et c'est pour
ça que d'ailleurs le ministère avait
fait un certain nombre d'appels à
candidature à des des associations avec
plus d'une dizaine d'associations et
nous avons contractualisé avec quatre
autres peut-être sur le contrôle
d'honorabilité ça on passe à un à un
autre sujet dont on a beaucoup parlé
dans cette commission également depuis
quand procédez-vous au contrôle de de
l'honorabilité donc on a dit un 3/4 ce
n'est pas 100
% quand pensez-vous peut-être arriver à
100 % de contrôle
d'honorabilité et Monsieur issouen ind
dit que 30 % des des éducateurs
n'étaient pas contrôlés donc voilà
peut-être avoir des éléments
là-dessus alors notre difficulté elle
est technique à priori puisque nous nous
avons tous les licenciers qui se
déclarent comme encadrant c'est une
obligation donc quand on rempli sa fiche
licence à la Fédération et que l'on est
encadrant on a une annexe supplémentaire
ces annexes là elles sont remplies et
après vous avez la procédure techniqu et
les difficultés techniques de la
plateforme et c'est pour ça qu'on est à
à 25% de moins là-dessus donc pour nous
c'est des faisabilités techniques parce
que nous voulons contrôler 100 % enfin
pour nous cette mesure elle est
protectrice pour l'institution donc nous
on veut arriver à 100 % et globalement
tous les gens remplissent leur leur
formulaire adéquat il y avait des
problématiques dont on a beaucoup
entendu parler quand on était Corse ou
quand on était né après certaines années
s' plantait donc voilà l'objectif c'est
d'arriver à faire 100 % à court terme on
a mis en place parce que j'ai oublié de
répondre à cette question là dès la
première année je crois que c'est la
deuxème année qu'on met en place ce
contrôle d'honorabilité dès la première
année on a on a joué le jeu complètement
en tout cas c'est notre
volonté on a
des toujours un questionnement autour de
ce contrôle d'honorabilité puisque
visiblement il existe depuis 2006 si je
ne dis pas de
bêtises 6 ou 2008 en tout cas ça existe
depuis très longtemps mais la plateforme
est arrivée plus tard donc voilà donc
vous vous faites référence à la mise en
place de la plateforme très certainement
je découvre aujourd'hui que
c'était que ça existe avant et je m'en
excuse vous inquiétez pas c'est nous
aussi on on a découvert plein de choses
sur le contrôle d'honorabilité donc pas
de problème à la question de savoir ce
qui manquait pour lutter contre les
violences sexuelles monsieur issouliier
répondait toujours au parisiens il
faudrait que toutes les fédérations
puissent avoir accès à une plateforme
commune lors de la prise de licence vous
entrez un nom une date de naissance s'il
y a un souci un message vous demande
sans div quoi que ce soit de vous
rapprocher de tel ou tel service de
l'État est-ce que vous avez demandé la
mise en place d'une telle plateforme au
ministère des
Sports oui on a même parlé sous le la
présidente présidente auocnosf ça fait
partie des choses sur lequell nous cro
ENF on y croit beaucoup une plateforme
enfin comment voulez-vous avoir un suivi
des interdits entre guillemets si vous
avez pas de plateforme unifiée donc oui
ça nous semble très
important comme on l'a dit aussi ça
serait très important de d'avoir
aussi peut-être pas des gens qui nous
contrôlent dans le sens des pour pouvoir
quantifier aussi
les qui on passe en commission de
discipline derrière c'est difficile de
donner des des sanctions si on n'est pas
tous sur une même logique des fois moi
même le premier je des fois je fais
appel parce que je trouve que la
sanction elle correspond pas à ce que
moi je ressens et c'est vrai que comme
l'a dit Laurent si vous changez demain
vous allez à nage avec Palm et cetera
bah ce qui a été fait sur la Fédération
d'adaptation vous êtes dans une autre
fédération c'est ça disparaît donc c'est
vrai que une plateforme c'est très
important je vous l'ai dit dans mes
propos liminires je pense que c'est très
important et aussi au-delà de de de
cette plateforme aussi peut-être avoir
avec l'État une réflexion sur comment
codifier un petit peu mieux les
sanctions par rapport encore une fois
les gens qui sont dans dans dans le
comité d'éthique et de dentologie et
dans dans la chambre de discipline ce
sont des bénévoles donc même si ce sont
des gens qui sont hautement qualifiés
puisque la chambre des cpin nous avons
isabeth clin qui est une juge aux
affaires familial voilà c'est des gens
qui sont habitués mais encore une fois
ce sont des des bénévoles dans le comité
d'éthique et d' théologie nous avons
neuf membres déjà on a une grosse
difficulté à trouver des membres qui
sont prêtes à donner de leur temps libre
c'est pas évident à les trouver mais
encore une fois ce sont des gens qui
n'ont pas forcément on n pas un guide
quoi donc je pense que ça serait très
important suite à vos travaux qu'on
arrive peut-être après à arriver à à
suggérer en tout cas que on arrive à des
choses beaucoup plus aidé pour les
fédérations alors juste peut-être depuis
quand vous faites cette demande de
plateforme au ministère des sport et et
au CNOSF et que vous a répondu le
ministère des sport à ce
sujet ça fait partie des travaux quand
on est on n pas de mot de demande formel
je vais pas vous ressortir un courrier
de 2021 mais ça fait partie des travaux
que l'on a mené lors du du
renouvellement des instances du CNOSF
donc en 2000 en 2021 si je ne dis pas de
bêtises ça fait partie des des dialogues
qu'on a avec le ministère des sports
mais on s'est jamais levé sur une
barricade en demandant cette plateforme
là mais on estime que ça fait partie des
choses qui qui seraiit hyper
importante et pour revenir sur le comité
d'éthique donc depuis quand avez-vous ce
comité d'éthique et le DTN est chargé de
veiller au respect de la loi la loi
prévoit que la fédération doit garantir
l'indépendance du comité d'éthique c'est
pourquoi il est surprenant que Monsieur
essouen n'ait pas été en mesure de nous
dire qui a nommé les membres du comité
d'éthique de la FFN il n'est pas revenu
vers nous sur ce point pouvez-vous nous
donner cette information alors bien
évidemment le le comité d'éthique les
les membres sont proposés par le
président au comité directeur c'est le
le mode de dévolution le comité
d'éthique il a été créé en 2018 à la
Fédération ça faisait partie des
éléments programmatiques de l'élection
de Gilles saisonnial en 2017 et
effectivement la
loi a été corrélative avec la création
et nous l'avons créé en 2018 c'était
Sébastien rouau qui était un ancien
champion de natation qui l'a présidé
pendant plus de 5 ans il a quitté ses
fonctions fin 2022 et a été remplacé par
Dominique contensous comme l'a dit
gésonial c'est complexe de trouver des
gens parce qu'en fait pour qu'ils soient
indépendant ils ne peuvent pas être dans
une instance régionale dans une instance
départemental il donc il faut arriver à
trouver à la fois des gens indépendants
et qui sont prêts à donner de leur temps
qui ont une vraie Valance en matière de
déontologie donc c'est effectivement
assez complexe on a eu deux démissions
dans les dans les deux dernières années
et et et nous avons eu euh nous avons eu
du un peu de mal à trouver des des des
candidats pour pour faire ce
travail-là et les postes vacants ont-ils
été remplacés alors pour être absolument
exact ils sont en cours de validation du
comité directeur de la fédération depuis
lundi donc il ils n'y auront plus de
postees vacants à l'issue de ce
vote juste pourquoi il y a eu des
démission ah c'est c'est assez simple
toutes les démissions sont sont sont
sont les mêmes ce ce sont des des des on
on a on avait fait le choix d'avoir
beaucoup de jeunes euh dont deux
personnes qui travaillent à Paris 2024
et qui pour des contraintte d'agenda
n'ont pas plus plus donner de temps
parce que globalement ça prend quand
même au moins une demi-journée par mois
et pour le président un peu
plus peut-être aussi pour précéder ce
que vous avez me poser comme question ce
n'est pas des gens que je connais
forcément quand je les propose c'est
parce que on fait on fait tourner un
petit peu dans tous les sens euh tout le
monde essaie de trouver des gens on nous
ramène effectivement des candidatures on
les reçoit avec Laurent on discute et
puis quand il y en a un qui est vraiment
motivé et c'est pas facile et
effectivement dans ce cas-là je le
propose mais il n'y a pas du tout de de
lien en général avec le président pour
pour désigner ces personnes
là alors avant de passer à un autre
sujet moi je voulais juste revenir un
tout petit peu sur le contrôle
d'honorabilité parce que vous avez dit
qu'il y avait des lacunes dans ce
contrôle donc on a évoqué la question de
la plateforme est-ce que vous avez
d'autres
recommandations sur ce sujet du contrôle
d'honorabilité pour en améliorer le
dispositif les les principales sont sur
la plateforme aujourd'hui elle est quand
même extrêmement complexe je vous ai dit
que ça faisait 2 ans qu'on faisait le
contrôle de d'honorabilité j'ai repris
mes notes effectivement ça fait même la
3è année parce que nous avions été euh
fédération faisant partie des des des
fédérations pilotes sur la saison 2021-
2022 pour le tester donc je je je pense
vraiment c'est les outils qui
permettront d'aller beaucoup plus
loin parce qu'après sinon le contrôle en
lui-même est est bon c'est un criblage
classique fait par les services de
l'État donc j'imagine que voilà et les
difficultés ce sont des majuscules des
accents des tirés des lieux de naissance
dans les dans les outrmers voilà ce sont
des choses très techniques qui on
l'espère seront rapidement et encore une
fois et on le redit on insiste s'il y
avait une base commune des licenciés on
on éviterait d'avoir une double saisie
pour arriver à un contrôle
efficace je pense que les problématiques
viennent souvent de la prise de licence
je connais pas toutes les fédérations
mais ça se fait très manuellement
souvent c'est des secrétaire dans un
club qui vont rentrer la licence c'est
pas forcément le licencié qui rendre sa
licence donc ce qui peut expliquer
souvent quand c'est mal orthographié que
la personne qui est derrière qui va
rentrer la licence ben c'est c'est pas
forcément la bonne orthographe du nom et
ça entraî évidemment plein de de
problématique au niveau de la plateforme
là aussi si on arrivait à centraliser
d'avoir un logiciel peut-être commun
dans les fédérations sur les prises de
licence ça serait quand même une grande
avancée lorsque vous faites ce contrôle
d'honorabilité est-ce que vous avez un
vous avez déjà eu des retours sur des
personnes que vous avez rentré dans le
logiciel alors oui j'ai pas le nombre il
y en a eu et qui ont abouti à des
suspensions de
licence nous avons centralisé une
possibilité de suspendre toute licence
dans l'heure pour que la personne ne
puisse plus
exercer d'accord donc vous faites pas de
distinction sur le statut de la
personne je vous pose la question parce
que dimanche voilà mais vous avez
compris j'ai compris votre question nous
on suspend la licence c'estàd qu'on on
suspend pas l'activité compétiteur
l'activité
encadrement licence est suspendu
point
oh pardon sur la probité des instan
dirigeante les obligations
réglementaires et légales sur ce sujet
sont-elles respectées et avez-vous
réalisé une cartographie des risques
d'atteinte à la
probité alors nous avons mis en œuvre la
loi et strictement la loi en demandant
au vice-président trésorier secrétaire
général président de transmettre à la
Haute Autorité de la lutteà donc ça ça a
été entièrement fait ça c'est le premier
point et j'ai oublié votre deuxième
question je suis désolé et avez-vous
réalisé une cartographie des risques
d'atteinte à la alors nous avons été
contrôlés par l'agence française
antiorruption il y a maintenant quelques
mois qui nous a mis dans ses
préconisation la création de cette carte
pour la fin de l'année 2023 donc elle
est en cours de création on a monté une
cellule dédiée pour créer pour créer
cette cette cartographie donc qui doit
rendre ses travaux fin
décembre
merci la Fédération s'est engagée dans
le contrat de délégation qui l' liie à
l'état à se doter d'un dispositif de
formation au risque de corruption
comment sera organisé ce dispositif et
quand sera-t-il
opérant alors nous nous avions pour idée
euh de l'intégrer dans nos différentes
formation c'est-à-dire que c'était
plutôt un module qu' venait la
Fédération dans sa dans dans dans son
niveau de de répartition des charges à
ce qu'on appelle le breuffet fédéral
numéro 5 le de le deses en gestion donc
dans ces diplôme on va dire de plus haut
niveau et elle va demander à ses airfans
c'estes ligue régional de de formation
d'inclure également ces modules là mais
l'idée c'est d'inclure des modules dans
chacune de nos formations plutôt qu'une
formation
dédiée
merci messieur merci de votre
disponibilité et vous n'hésitez pas à
nous faire retour des différents
éléments dont dont nous avons parlé
précédemment tout a été noté on vous
remercie également Merci à
VOUS vouz rajouter autre
chose non moi je pense qu'en conclusion
et encore une fois
c'est je pense que toute la difficulté
c'est d'arriver à faire évoluer les
mentalités encore une fois sans les
brusquer je défends pas ma fédération à
mes clubs je suis issu d'un club euh
c'est vrai que ce que j'ai disais dans
dans les propos en introduction c'est
que aujourd'hui on est on est moi
j'entends souvent vous la Fédération là
haut alors que la Fédération c'est tous
les c'est tous les gens qui sont
licenciés la fédération mais c'est vrai
que on a cette difficulté de faire
comprendre les choses encore une fois
nous sommes pas une grande fédération
même si on a 400000 licenciers mais les
moyens financiers sont sont ceux qui
sont on s'appuie énormément sur le
bénévola et je pense qu'il faut arriver
à être très pédagogue arriver à faire en
sorte que les gens on les entraîne dans
une attitude positive sans les brusquer
parce que sinon ça serait la catastrophe
aujourd'hui il y aurait pas de
fédération sans c'est des milliers de
personnes qui donnent de leur temps et
encore une fois des fois on est perçu
comme étant un peu des des enququineurs
que de leur imposer beaucoup de choses
mais mais voilà il faut arriver à faire
évoluer le monde sportif dans la France
d'aujourd'hui avec une fédération qui
s'appuie à 80 % 90 % sur des bénévoles
pour faire fonctionner cette fédération
donc c'est vrai que le parisianisme
c'est une chose mais derrière l'État
c'est c'est perçu pareil que que nous
hein et que il faut il faut être modéré
entre guillemets et et faire de la
pédagogie essayer de former essayer de
de modifier bien évidemment pour avoir
avoir une meilleure un meilleur rendu de
des situations encore une fois c'est
c'est très c'est un jeu d'équilibre
encore une fois voilà moi je dis pas
qu'on a tout bien fait je pense qu'on a
été élu ça fait 6 ans
euh on est des bénévoles moi même je
suis un bénévole on prend de notre temps
c'est vrai que on peut être critiqué
hein c'est c'est jamais tout est
vraiment pas tout bien fait mais voilà
je pense qu' depuis 2017 on a fait quand
même énormément évoluer la gouvernance
de notre fédération et il reste encore
des choses à faire mais j'ai bon espoir
d'arriver à les
faire vous avez combien de licenciés à
la Fédération
402000 pour la première fois j'ai pris
la Fédération on était à
300000000 Merci à VOUS euh n'oubliez pas
juste de nous transmettre vous savez le
rapport qu'on vous a demandé les
informations parfait retrouve la version
a ser quand
même plus utile pour nous merci merci à
vous
merci